قد يكون الصمت مريحا للاعصاب لكنه في هذه
الحاله قد يسبب الهلوسه فاذا جلست داخل
هذه الغرفه التي لقبت بالاهداف في العالم
صدقني لن تتمكن من البقاء هنا طويلا فيمكن
ان تصاب بالجنود لكن لماذا تم تصميم هذه
الغرفه
الغرفه استحدثتها شركه مايكروسوفت بمقرها
الرئيسي بالعاصمه واشنطن عام 2004 لا
تدخلها اصوات العالم الخارجي بنسبه
99.99
ولتحقيق ذلك تتكون جدرانها من ست طبقات من
الخرسانه والفولاذ ومن الداخل تم وضع
اوتاد زجاجيه على جدران الغرفه وسقفها
لكسر الموجات الصوتيه قبل ارتدادها لم
يتمكن احد من الجلوس فيها اكثر من 45
دقيقه لان الانسان يسمع فيها صوت دقات
قلبه وجريان الدم في اذنه الامر الذي
يقوده للهلوسه او الجنون
اما استخدامها فيكون الاختبار جوده الصوت
في منتجات شركات التكنولوجيا كما تستعين
بها وكاله ناسا للفضاء لمعرفه قدره رواد
الفضاء على تحمل الصمت الفضائي قبل ان
تتاثر حواسهم في النهايه لابد من سؤالك هل
تود تجربه الجلوس داخل هذه الغرفه